quand la BA piierre est arrivée à à RTL
à c'est c'est Radio Luxembourg à ce
moment-là euh et qu'il a demandé à à
lire son son papier on lui a dit non
d'abord et puis en en fait il a il a
poussé la porte quoi c'était il y a 70
ans le 1er février
1954 il faut que ce soir même dans
toutes les villes de France dans chaque
quartier de Paris des pancartes
s'accrochent sous une lumière dans la
nuit à la porte de lieu où il y ait
couverture paille soupe et où on lise
sous
centre fraternel de dépannage c'estes
simples mot toi qui souffre qui que tu
sois entre dors mange reprend espoir ici
on t'aime pourquoi il a fait cet appel
il était à courbe voie il essayait de
mobiliser des gens pour donner à manger
pour CER bon
et pendant la conférence il est
interrompu par un coup de téléphone de
compagnons qui lui
disent ce soir on allait distribuer des
sandwiches dans Paris on remontait le
boulevard sébastopo au feu rouge on a vu
un tchifon on s'est dit ben c'est
intéressant on va prendre le tchifon et
dans le tchifon il y avait une vieille
dame qui était morte de froid et qui
tenait sur elle son son son papier par
lequel il elle avait été expulsée et
c'est c'est donc ça qui a qui a mobilisé
la bapierre il en a parlé au
journalistes qui était avec lui qui
s'appelait George verprat et ensemble
ils ont rédiger cet appel que le
lendemain ils allaient les dire à à la
radio nationale et puis ensuite à
RTL c'est l'hiver thermomètre à - 15 et
la Marne gelé aux portes de Paris
l'hiver terrible l'hiver tragique on
était au sortir de la guerre 54 c'est
sortir de la guerre les gens avaient
connu ce que c'était que l'exode ce que
c'était que les difficultés pour
alimenta ce que c'était que le froid ils
avaient connu ça et la guerre était
passée il s'était dit dit ben c'est fini
et puis tout d'un coup un curé qui est
là qui qui lance cet appel ça y est ça
recommence il y a vraiment des gens en
difficulté faut qu'on se mobilise et ça
a été l'insurrection de la bonté hein ce
qu'ils ont appelé l'insurrection de la
bonté mais c'était vraiment très très
fort oui on ressent toute cette cette
aventure c'est c'est C ces mobilisations
c'est c'estes tous ces gens qui se sont
mobilisés à ce moment-là et avec un à la
fraternité les paquets de couverture de
vêtements affluaient et ce ne sont pas
seulement des riches qui ont donné
quelque chose pour stocker ses dons une
directrice d'hôtel à Paris s'est portée
volontaire quand il a fait l'appel de 54
donnez-moi des des des des poils
catalytiques des couvertures amenez-moi
des matelas et cetera et cetera mais le
speaker lui dit mais où où on vous les
AM vous les amenz à l'hôtel Rochester et
Madame l'armier la Directrice de l'hôtel
a vu arriver débouler tout un tas de
gens qui se sont pointés avec des coutes
qu'elle comprenaient pas pourquoi les
gens se sont rués sur leur placard
ramasser des le des vêtements
ramasser des des comment des couvertures
des des matelas et ell se sont rué ru de
la boessie où se trouvait l'hôtel pour
pouvoir
déposer le leur matériel et puis il y a
eu aussi beaucoup d'argent qui est
arrivé comme on était dans un hôtel il y
avait des salles de on remplissait les
baignoirs avec le fric qui nous arrivait
parce que cette époque là on pouvait
envoyer de l'argent par par courrier
c'est les choses qu'on ne fait plus
maintenant l'appel dépasse les
frontières avec le don généreux d'une
star de cinéma c'est Charlot l'homme s
toi des temps modernes qui vient tendre
la main au si
[Musique]
d'aujourd'hui c'est une belle archive
celleel aussi Charlot B pierre il
appelait Charlot il disait toujours
Charlot Charlie chapeline a donné 2
millions de de francs de l'époque à à à
la BA pierre c'était et il disait euh
euh je ne vous donne pas cet argent je
vous le rends dès 1954 grâce à l'appel
de l'abbé Pierre 10000 logements
d'urgence ont été construits en France
et 2 ans plus tard en 1956 la trêve
hivernale a été instaurée 70 ans plus
tard en 2024 la appel de l'abé pierre
raisonne encore et ses membres restent
mobilisés il faut qu'on se mobilise il
faut qu'on qu'on dise ce qu'on a à dire
c'est c'est pourquoi je trouve que la
Fondation elle fait ce boulot là elle
est elle dénonce elle n'arrête pas de
dénoncer et ça c'est vachement important